So finally, if the transaction commits by calling
an end transaction, at that point, all the
changes that have been made to persistent data
structures have to be written to the log
segment that records the redo logs for this
application. So at this point, LRVM creates a
redo log in memory of the changes That
have been made to the persistent data structures.
That is, this region that has been modified, it's
going to be written as a redo log. See it doesn't
know within that region, LRVM does not know within this
region specified by base address and the length. Where exactly
these data structures are contained. All it knows is
that, this is the portion of the address space that
is being modified in the critical section, that's why it's
so important as a developer to make sure that the
data structures that you manipulating within this region,
that you have signalled LRVM. LRVM is basically thinking
that there is a continuous set of addresses starting
here for a certain length that may have been
modified in this critical section. So, the log record
that it writes is basically saying, here is the
start address, and here is the number of bytes,
and this is the new data that goes into
this virtual address base, that's what LRVM is
creating As a redo log in memory. Remember
that redo log is itself a data structure
of LVRM in memory which should not confuse the
redo log with the external data segments. External
data segments are the persistent versions of the in
memory data structures. Now this redo log Is
the changes that are being made to the in
memory version of the persistent data structures, that
have not should been committed to the disk in
terms of internal data segments. It's now available
at this point at the end of end transaction,
it's available as a redo log entry. In
the log segment which was initialized by this application.
And the semantics of this transaction is, if it
commits, then all of these changes are now available
on persistent storage. So, what the LRVM library has to
do is Not only create the redo log record, which
is a data structure in memory so far as LRVM
is concerned, but it also has to flush these redo logs
to the disk at the point of commit. And only
after that, we can assume that all the changes that have
been made in this critical section Has been persistent on
the disk, so he has to flush to the disk synchronously,
meaning that this end transaction waits for this
redo log to be flushed to the disk.
At this point it is on the disk, however, again [LAUGH] in order to make sure
that we can have a perfomance implementation of
LRVM, there is a mode available in the
end transaction, and this mode. Says no flush,
meaning at the point of end transaction, you don't
neccessarily have to block the caller for
the flush to be complete. Transaction semantics would
require that the process that is executing this
commit should not be allowed to go past
this point until. The synchronised IO has completed
from the redo log into the disk but
in order to make it a more performance
conscious design, if you think that power failures
array and the chance is that your server is
going to crash is not very high, then you can
go ahead and say as a developer that At
the point of end transaction, I want you to committed
by the way, you don't have to block me.
In other words, this mode if it says no flush,
it is saying that yes, I want you committed
to the disk, but don't block me from going further.
So, the changes that are being made As a
redo log record will be committed to the disk
later depending on this specification of no flush. So
as a developer if I say no flush, then the
redo log is not going to be synchronously written to
the disk. So I can go ahead. I might
do another transaction. That might write More log records,
so I can review the number of I/O operations in
committing these log records to the disk. So
that's an opportunity that I'm exploiting by giving
this no flush mode in the end transaction.
So, it's an opportunity for the application to
both reduce the number of I/O operations. And
also make sure that the application is not
blocked here, waiting for the synchronous rights to
the disk to complete. So once the transaction
is committed, meaning that LRVM has created
the redo log for this particular transaction, then
the undo record is no longer needed because
undo record, if you recall, was created Just
for the eventuality that this transaction may not
commit, but now that the transaction is committed,
we can throw away this undo record. On
the other hand, instead of the end transaction,
the transaction may actually abort. If it aborts,
then what. LRVM has to do is restore
this portion of the virtual address space of
this process from the undo record so that we
have gone back to the state before this
transaction ever happened. So in other words, we
are making whatever code that the server executed
as a critical section code between begin transaction and
abort transaction. To go away, and we
restore the computation to its state before
the begin transaction by copying the undo record into the portion of the virtual
data space that has been modified through this critical section code. That in a
nutshell is how you would use the primitives provided by LRVM in constructing A
server, that, has certain persistence requirement.